une avant-première à paris du dernier
film de xavier dolan a cette
particularité
l'événement n'est pas son casting de
stars vous êtes là pour kit harington
les réalisateurs d'une génération dont
on attend ses films mais quand face à
chaque fois en fait ce film ça fait 30
ans j'ai l'impression qu'on attend
qu'ils n'arrêtent pas d'en parler et
c'est vraiment bon on considère un peu
comme un génie vu son âge du travail
qu'il a fait il a déjà plein de films à
son actif vous espérer le faire signer
un autographe sur tous les trains le
dire lui dire ce que ce que je ressens
par rapport à son travail et par rapport
à ce qu'il a pu m'apporter dans la vie
parce que je le suis depuis chez au
collège on a l'impression qu'ils nous
montrent nous il est un réalisateur au
parcours hors norme un modèle pour sa
génération qui voue un culte à momy un
million d'entrées un prodige
il fait ce mois-ci ses 30 ans et a déjà
tourné huit films un cinéaste québécois
accueillis en france comme une rock star
son dernier film ma vie avec john f
donovan et son premier film en anglais
avec un casting hollywoodien
il arrive enfin après une gestation
épique suivi par toutes ses fans days
c'est le meilleur je suis sincèrement
dans la vie vous donner la liste que
j'ai lue devant des séries ce soir j'ai
dû deuxième qu'il existe deux jours de
l'année ses fans c'est une drôle
d'histoire d'amour une histoire d' idole
et d'admirateurs c'est justement ce que
raconte donovan le film qui raconte le
mieux payé de l'année
[Musique]
en effet le petit garçon qui court chez
lui retrouver son héros préféré à la
télé pas besoin de chercher midi à
quatorze heures pour savoir qui c'est
c'est peut-être le film qui dit le plus
de choses sur javier dolan le gamin qui
a incarné par jack up tremblay c'est son
prolongement c'est xavier dolan qui
regardent ces feuilletons américains
quand ils étaient jeunes qui s'extasient
devant devant l'univers des stars qui a
les yeux qui brillent
il ya plusieurs points de départ mais
c'est sûr que le plus fort c'est moi ou
mon admiration très jeunes pour des
feuilletons américains puis des acteurs
en fait qui me paraissait tellement
inaccessible que j'admirais que
j'idolâtre et puis probablement
quelqu'un que j'aimais je veux dire que
j'aimais amoureusement
d'ailleurs la scène est magnifique jacob
tremblay hystérie qui nous transmet
cette hystérie tous les gens qui ont été
fan et qui sont fans aujourd'hui de qui
que ce soit se retrouvent dans cette
hystérie
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à cet instant il faut imaginer xavier
dolan huit ans enfants de la télé et
acteurs de pub déjà attiré par la
lumière
[Musique]
c'est l'âge où il découvre titanic tombe
en pâmoison devant leonardo dicaprio et
prend sa plus belle plume pour lui
écrire une lettre qu'il s'amuse
aujourd'hui à relire en public
[Musique]
xavier dolan tadros ego comme x files
notes donnant à grasse ces lettres
laissées sans réponse de l'annoncé la
matière première de son film il utilise
la fiction pour corriger le réel car le
petit rouperte du film entretient lui
une correspondance avec son idole john f
donovan une star dans le placard ma vie
avec john f donovan ça parle de role
models ça parle de ces personnalités
qu'on idolâtre et qu'on a envie de
devenir et il ya une mise en abyme assez
drôle oui c'est vrai que lui même est
devenu un rôle modèle pour ceux qui
aiment son cinéma le rôle modèle celui
qui inspire les plus jeunes c'est
désormais lui
dolan né au festival de cannes il ya dix
ans avec un film électrochoc j'ai tué ma
mère réalisé à 19 ans financé en partie
avec ses cachets d'enfants acteurs il
n'a cessé de monter les marches
quasi un film par an les amours
imaginaires laurence anyways avant
d'exploser à 25 ans avec momie
l'histoire à la fois tendre et violente
d'une mère et son fils atteint de
troubles psychiques grosses tâches
banales d'autres
le film secoue la croisette repart avec
le prix du jury mais remporte la fameuse
palme du coeur son discours marquant à
cannes lorsqu'il a reçu le prix du jury
alors qu'il aurait dû avoir la palme
d'or soyons sérieux
et bien ce discours-là a eu un
retentissement énorme je crois qu'il ya
vraiment eu un avant et un après là d'un
coup le gamin qui est devant sa télé et
qui en tant que xavier dolan dire je
pense que tout est possible a qui rêvent
aux travail aidé abandonne jamais et
puis si je l'espère ce prix en être la
preuve la plus rayonnante au départ dans
ce discours là à changer la donne et
d'un coup c'est devenu une sorte de pot
pour certains à cet angle c'est génial
d'exemples de d'exemple à suivre
l'un de ses bébés de l'âne s'appelle
nathan ambrosio ni il a 19 ans et vient
de sortir son premier film les drapeaux
de papier dans la chambre où il
travaille
la fiche de momie est en bonne place
c'était un déclencheur je me suis dit on
alors peut-être qu'on a le droit de
faire des films comme ça peut-être qu'on
a le droit de faire du cinéma quand on a
envie de faire du cinéma il faut pas
être attendre une école ou d'avoir 30
ans minimum
c'est un nom plus tard que je me suis
vraiment dit j'écris les paroles papier
et peut-être que je pourrais aussi faire
maintenant que j'ai envie de faire du
cinéma peut-être que comme lui on me
laissera la chance de le faire et
finalement que ses vélos l'un de ses
réalisateurs iconix et c'est vrai il
incarne quelque chose du cinéma la
jeunesse c'est le pour moi c'est le
nouveau mentor du cinéma des jeunes et
d'un mentor on espère toujours quelques
mots un petit signe une onction
récemment il m'a envoyé un message il
m'a envoyé votre chance pour votre film
elle m'a envoyé un message et la
commenter une nouvelle faute on sent pas
une chance pour être filmé et je vous
donnais j'étais dans le métro quand j'ai
vu ça et je me suis arrêté et je me suis
mis à rire de lorgues et 3 ça n'avait
aucun sens les gens me prenaient pour un
fou mais c'est pas grave je le recevais
un message de noël de l'année et c'est
hélas depuis ce message me dit un jour
on se croisera
au même âge xavier dolan répondait à des
interviews dehors sur un banc et ne
cachait pas son besoin d'être admiré et
faille de moody's la boucle est bouclée
celui qui dit faire des films pour être
aimé et désormais adulé combien sont
ceux qui pourraient écrire ma vie avec
sa vie' de l'âne
[Musique]